on a tiré et on a pointé à guyancourt le
club local a organisé ce dimanche 24
février au centre sportif les trois
mousquetaires son traditionnel tournoi
officiel niveau promotion un rendez-vous
en doublettes mixtes qui a tiré
principalement des joueurs des yvelines
c'est le premier de l'année donc oui
c'est un rendez vous important
il a fait très beau donc évidemment ça
ça joue beaucoup sur sur la journée nous
avons eu beaucoup d' équipe à peu près
une centaine d' équipe nous ne
l'espérions pas donc ça se passe très
bien
parmi les participants beaucoup de
seniors mais également une dizaine de
jeunes qui ont décidé de se lancer en
doublettes c'est le cas de saïd 28 ans
ce guillon courtois commencé à pratiquer
la pétanque avec son beau père
aujourd'hui ce sportif en fait
régulièrement on va dire les jeunes ont
moins d'expérience donc du coup ils vont
pas forcément dans les compétitions mais
là ça prend de plus en plus de jeunes
qui sont qui trouve qu'en fait c'est pas
simplement en sport on a dû ronger des
boules mais ça demande de la précision
cette technique est bien plus on
progresse dans ce port là et pas plus on
voit que le sport en fait très rare à
haut niveau est très difficile les
jeunes et les moins jeunes se retrouvent
le 10 mars prochain pour un nouveau
tournoi officiel à guyancourt
l'occasion pour saïd de peaufiner encore
son geste